Zelda it's one of Nintendo's most
prolific franchises you got your Mario
and you got your Zelda boom that's a
Nintendo I mean if you walk up to some
Rando on the street and ask them do you
know A tingle they're gonna say yes
because it was on America's Most Wanted
last week but did you know at one point
Zella was on the brink of failure this
is the story of how the Legend of Zelda
Twilight Princess saved the Zelda
franchise
[Music]
please
when Shigeru Miyamoto hit the Mean
Streets of Nintendo back in 1977 he
quickly Rose to internal stardom after
creating Donkey Kong out of unsold
arcade Machines of radar scope in 1981.
then came the famicom NES in the West
[Music]
with the Japanese release of the famicom
Miyamoto worked on two games that would
come to Define Nintendo devil world and
excitebike
but afterwards he would simultaneously
work on two little games at the same
time Super Mario Brothers released in
1985.
and The Legend of Zelda released in
1986.
[Music]
again he worked on these at the same
time which is insane to me these two
games were Mega successes for Nintendo
Super Mario Brothers sold around 3
million copies within four months in
Japan alone and became a system seller
and a huge reason that NES succeeded in
the west meanwhile The Legend of Zelda
sold 1 million units on its first day in
Japan alone and afterwards these two
games would become Nintendo's pair of
golden geese laying critically acclaimed
system sellers one after another in fact
we have a whole video about Zelda's
games and our excellently written
history of Zelda video by Lucy James so
fast forward to this
you got your Mario 64.
Zelda Ocarina of Time
these two games defined and set the
stage for 3D games to comment in all of
gaming while Zelda was back and forth
one of Nintendo's largest properties
Ocarina of Time absolutely blew the
other games out of the water as the
fourth best-selling game of all time on
the N64 with 7.6 million copies sold
we're talking about a game that wasn't
only fantastic as one of the few 10 out
of 10 meme games of all time but a
trendsetter Ocarina of times lock on Z
targeting is still used to this day it
defined and still continues to Define
how to handle action in a 3D space and
Majora's Mask in our opinion
was weird as and seriously one of
my favorite Zelda games so the stage and
hype was set for Nintendo's next system
the Nintendo GameCube everybody and I
mean everybody was looking forward to
what new Mario game was coming and what
new Zelda game was coming
then spaceworld 2000.
foreign
[Applause]
consumers were looking for a brand new
super mature Zelda with ultra realistic
Graphics at least realistic compared to
you know
this but the thing is while Western
audiences loved it ejawanoma hated it
mainly reviews of manly reviews what are
you doing here oh I have a green screen
nothing's real
by the way manly did an amazing video on
the same topic and if you haven't seen
it
you should so agnuma took one look at
the sick battle between link and
Ganondorf and Zed
nah this isn't Zelda this isn't Zelda at
all and instead of this
he gave us this
[Music]
there's a long-running perception that
this was biyamoto's favorite version of
link as he always wanted Zelda to be a
cartoon that's a lie Miyamoto hated Toon
Link when he had to present the game
against his will he told awanoma that it
wasn't too late to make the graphics
realistic regardless if you think the
game's amazing or not which it was by
the way reception in the West
um not so good after witnessing the cool
more mature version of the hero of time
Western audiences were not stoked when
they instead saw this Leapfrog version
of link that looked like he belonged in
Coco melon
this is a disgrace to the Zelda
franchise I wanted mature and I got
five-year-olds why why why this is
disgusting I have never seen this game
I just hope this is a cruel joke but it
doesn't matter what I think what matters
is what Nintendo thought even though the
GameCube itself underperformed according
to agnuma Zelda's numbers were
incredibly disappointing in Japan while
the New Direction hadn't appealed as
many people in the west which was now
becoming a Marcus Zelda would rely upon
so the team thought about what the issue
was and decided it was
Innovation sure
okay clearly if they made an Innovative
Zelda game with a brand new style of
gameplay they'd be able to reel back in
Japanese players so the solution was
clear two castles baby
what that's a terrible idea the game was
four Swords Adventures a follow-up to an
offshoot game bundled with the Legend of
Zelda A Link to the Past GBA port and
all players had to do to play as main
multiplayer feature was on a GameCube
and one Game Boy Advance per player as
each one would serve as a controller
yeah it didn't do well
I mean look the scores were fine but in
terms of sales we're talking less than
400 000 copies sold for a Legend of
Zelda game less than 400
000 later that year Capcom released the
Legend of Zelda the Minish Cap a more
traditional Zelda Adventure that sold
pretty well at 1.76 million copies but
really not much better than Metroid
Fusion which sold 1.6 million copies and
I'm sure you all know how rarely Metro
games have released since Metroid Fusion
and Prime 3.
so the question is was Zelda on the same
downward trajectory as Metroid Pokemon
Smash Brothers Mario Kart Mario and now
even sometimes Kirby we're starting to
outsell Zelda games with Zelda no longer
Nintendo's Golden Goose
so EJ Allen Norman decided to swallow
his pride in Wind Waker 2 baby what no
not at all why would you think that AJ
alanova decided to shake things up he
went back to the realistic Graphics in
the original GameCube presentation but
on a horse
behind the scenes AO Newman knew they
needed to try the more mature looking
link to relate to an older teen Western
demographic and Miyamoto didn't feel
like that was enough of a change for a
new Zelda he told the team they should
focus on horseback riding so four months
later the team had a very basic
prototype of horseback riding working
and dropped a surprise trailer at E3
2004 which garnered the prior reaction
and it was announced for fall of the
following year but there was one problem
there was no game notice how the trailer
has no subtitle it's just the Legend of
Zelda so it was time to hunker down and
decide what the hell this game was gonna
be on the positive front that standing
ovation and incredible reaction to the
trailer served as a huge motivation for
the team as they were excited by the
overwhelming response however they had
to come up with something new so the
team thought about how prior Zelda games
had alternate worlds light and dark and
linked to the past past and future in
Ocarina and decided to use this as
motivation what if they took link as a
rabbit from the Dark World and linked to
the past but made it cool what if they
made link a wolf Miyamoto
wasn't confident with the direction
where at the very least he didn't think
creating a four-legged creature would
work convincingly enough either way
inspired by Minish cap which was also
done in development using a similar
mechanic with its big and small worlds
asiao Numa and the Zelda team forged
forwards E3 2005 came a brand new
trailer and they decided on a title
Zelda TP
toilet paper
[Music]
but by E3 2005 just months before the
planned launch date how Numa wasn't
happy with the gameplay Innovations and
they still needed something major sure
fans were waiting three hours in line to
play it at E3 but to AO Numa the game
wasn't unique or good enough luckily
behind the scenes Nintendo was working
on something huge something
revolutionary the Nintendo Revolution
later known as the Nintendo Wii and
Miyamoto approached aonuma about
utilizing the new motion controller for
Zelda he thought this would be the
perfect Innovation to make Twilight
Princess stand out and unique from the
previous entries then satoru Iwata
wanted to push the game back to ensure
it was a masterpiece and told the team
they made something that was
120 Zelda whatever that means it was
decided to push back Twilight princess's
release date by year to make the game
available for both the Nintendo Wii as a
launch title and available for the
GameCube at the same time and the team
got to work incorporating their game
into the Nintendo Wii which they thought
would help in the Japanese Market
especially first they used the remote
which could point at the screen for
shooting Link's bow next they made us a
link would swing his sword when players
swung the remote because most players
are right-handed they flipped the entire
game and mirrored it on the Wii so link
who's usually left-handed would be
right-handed and the Nintendo Wii launch
came
so fall 2006 there I was little Dave
waiting outside of my local game store
overnight for my copy of a Nintendo Wii
and The Legend of Zelda Twilight
Princess and so too were three out of
every four people waiting in line for a
Wii in fact 87 percent of people who
purchased the Nintendo Wii at launch
also purchased the Legend of Zelda
Twilight Princess it went on to be so
successful that became the best-selling
Zelda title in the series until breath
of the wild even outselling Ocarina of
Time whereas Ocarina of Time sold 7.6
million copies Twilight Princess sold
8.85 million copies and for asiao Numa
it was a personal success as it was the
first game he'd ever made that his wife
both wanted to play and finished what
she did with her son
hey Marissa will you play Twilight
Princess with me no
but going back to the sales you can see
just how Stark of a contrast Twilight
Princess was for the team while it still
didn't sell as well as Mario Kart Mario
or smash it was still the highest
selling Zelda game ever and solidified
once again that Zelda was a franchise
worth putting the time and money into
it's easy to think Nintendo can do
whatever they want especially with the
franchise as popular Zelda but I want to
take a look at a quote from then
president of Nintendo satoru Iwata in a
conversation with Shigeru Miyamoto and
aegian Numa Upon finishing Twilight
Princess satoru iwadas says and I quote
even with all the resources we have here
at Nintendo we could only make something
like this once every few years in fact
it might not be easy to do something
like this again so I really want
everyone to have a wonderful time
playing this game but after the success
of Twilight Princess the next major game
in the franchise The Legend of Zelda
Skyward Sword went on to receive a
five-year development time and in a
regularly High budget from Nintendo
I don't think Zelda would have
completely died if Twilight Princess
wasn't successful but like Metroid
f-zero and Pikmin I do think the
trajectory this series would have
changed and we would have perhaps seen a
fewer zeldas or less time in budget
allotted to Future games and who knows
without it we might have never gotten
Skyward Sword as we did or more
importantly the team may have never
gotten the chance and time to make
breath of the wild today Zelda is bigger
than ever and that's all thanks to the
Legend of Zelda toilet paper thank you
so much for watching Once Again a huge
thank you to manly reviews for coming on
this episode I highly highly recommend
his own video on Twilight Princess as I
really personally love it and his
presentation style is incredible I know
I'm one of the few people who think this
but I'd actually rather replay Twilight
Princess than Ocarina of Time and look I
I know that Twilight Princess is like
the same game in a lot of ways but to me
it's a better Ocarina uh anyways I hope
you enjoyed this if you did please go
back and check out our episodes on Sonic
and Resident Evil 4 and next week we've
got an episode coming up on the Nintendo
switch